SPEAKER 1: Cennydd?
Excellent.
Cennydd it is a
designer and an author
and he has been looking
particularly at future ethics.
He's been advising different
companies like Samsung, Twitter
around the ethical
implications of technology.
Thank you.
CENNYDD: Thank you.
All design is
interested in behavior.
For interaction
design, that really
points in two directions
that interest.
One, we're interested
in designing
the behavior of a system
responding to user input.
But we're also interested in
the medium of human behavior.
And for all design,
what we consider
good design is often design that
directs behavior appropriately.
A design is successful if
the user can react in the way
that we'd planned for,
that we'd anticipated.
A good interface,
for instance, is
one that highlights the
right information in a system
so that the user is steered
to the next step in a process.
If we, say, enlarge
a button on a UI,
yes, it makes it more visible.
But the main point is, more
people will click that.
Because it's about
behavior, then, that
means design is laden
with ethical impact.
Indeed, you could say that
design is applied ethics.
I think it might have been
Cameron Tonkinwise who
argued that design is morality
practiced with the hands.
Now sometimes that relationship
is explicit and obvious.
If you're designing
razor wire, for instance,
you're saying that
people have a right
to privacy and to property
such that actually people
should be injured for
trying to contravene it.
If you design speed bumps, then
you're saying that a car cannot
travel down this road beyond a
certain speed without damaging
the owner's suspension.
In these instances, we're
delegating moral control
to the artifacts
in the environment.
But every act of design,
whatever the medium,
is about specifying the future.
It's about making
a claim for how
we think the future should be.
When we choose one
preferred future,
we also discard thousands
of alternatives.
And if design is really
around deciding what to make
and if ethics is really
about deciding how to live,
then there's clearly
some kind of relationship
between those two things.
So designers try persistently
to persuade people
to act in desirable ways.
And this is not a rational art.
If it were, it would
be fairly simple.
We'd present the
options available
and we'd leave it to the user
to make the rational choice.
But we know well
that other factors
influence decision making--
emotions, defaults, framing.
So designers have
to appeal in part
to the unpredictable aspects
of human nature-- in essence,
to human weakness.
Hence, nudge theory, which is
all about changing behavior
without changing the
options available.
It's all about the power
of framing and positioning.
So we know the common examples.
You can change defaults
to encourage opt-in
for, say, organ donation.
You can move the healthier
snacks by the tills
to encourage people to
make healthier choices.
And nudge, of course, has
been terrifically popular
in the public sector.
But Silicon Valley, I
think, likes it, as well.
Nudge doesn't trespass on
the individual freedoms
that the industry holds dear.
But it's still a very potent
way to liberate people
from their time and money.
Nudge generally, I think,
has a positive reputation
because its applications
are seen as positive.
We always talk
about it in relation
to things like weight
loss or smoking
cessation, financial prudence.
But of course, any
persuasive technique
has a potentially
less healthy purpose.
Designers, I think,
are particularly
familiar with this dichotomy.
Our industry designs
appealing cigarette packets
and the calming hospital signage
for the smoker's last days.
There's currently this panic
about persuasive technology
becoming addictive.
It's not one I'm quite
so concerned with.
I think the lines between a
product that's simply so good
that we want to come back to
it, it's so well-designed,
and one that's explicitly
designed to capture attention--
I think those lines are blurry.
There's also not so much
direct evidence at the moment
that technological addiction
is a separate disorder
from existing ones.
However, it's clear that chasing
engagement, that essentially
trying to persuade
people to reuse
our products on
a habitual basis,
has led to some very
trashy uses of technology.
This, of course, is the
fundamental goal, if you like,
of Tristan Harris's
Time Well Spent movement
to interrogate that
potential downside.
More interesting to me, though,
is the politics of nudging.
Because we find-- there's
a 2015 study that attitudes
to nudging actually
vary quite a bit
across the political spectrum.
Libertarians particularly
are skeptical of nudge
because they regard it as
the top of a slippery slope.
But we find that whatever
someone's political leanings,
the biggest way to
change their mind,
to change their
appetite for nudging,
is to show them examples that
they politically approve of,
or to say that the people
trying to institute these nudge
policies are politicians
that they happen to support.
The same study also found that
nudge can induce antagonism.
Some people-- mostly
right-leaning people--
deliberately chose
the alternative option
when they were told that they
were being nudged-- essentially
a protest vote.
Another study found that the
source of nudging matters.
US and Israeli
participants in this study
generally disliked nudges
that came from government
and authorities.
Instead, they
preferred employers
to be doing the nudging.
In Germany, there was
no such difference.
And we rarely talk
about the politics
of these persuasive angles,
even though Thaler and Sunstein,
the architects of nudge
theory, went as far as to call
nudge libertarian paternalism.
Technologies are, of
course, great platforms
for designing behavior change.
They sit atop oceans of data.
Online behavior, sure, but also
an increasingly datafied world
typified by computer vision,
by audio capture, IoT
and the smart city as
substrate for urban sensing.
We all know the now banal
cliche that data is the new oil.
But that contains some
interesting metaphors.
We now talk about oil with
these liquid figures of speech.
It's a deluge.
It's a torrent.
It's an uncontrollable
natural source.
It's no accident,
of course, that oil
is dangerous to
store at high volumes
and that it has a
habit of leaking.
We also now have the
computational ability
to make sense of
this ocean of data.
We have machine learning and
analytics tools to make sense
and to act upon these systems.
And this offers a
significant scale.
It means we can abstract
persuasion to the technologies
all around us, giving us
higher impact at lower cost.
But the common examples of
technology and its persuasive
potential, they're mostly
jejune and harmless.
Think of wearable
fitness trackers,
apps that remind you to
drink more water, and so on.
But we're starting, now,
to find deeper and more
eye-opening prospects.
Karen Yeung, who's a legal
scholar based in the UK,
says that we're entering an era
of what she calls hyper-nudge.
This is a persuasive
system that's
networked so that it can
learn from millions of people.
It's dynamic, so it's
able to shift strategies
unlike, for instance,
mass advertising.
And it's personalized,
potentially down
to the individual.
So this is a system that knows
intimately you and your data.
It can adapt to your behavior.
It can change its mind if
an approach doesn't work.
And it will, therefore, know
exactly which buttons to push.
This could be an
irresistible manipulator.
We already have crude variants
of this, already quite
effective and quite scalable.
Another study found 50% uplift
in Facebook ad click-throughs
simply by tailoring
the copy in the image
in the ad for very crude
personality types interpolated
from a user's likes.
This was a fairly
manual process,
but it's clear how
this can be automated.
50% is obviously a
very large uplift
through this particularly
crude human-operated algorithm.
Amazon already sent
millions of automated nudges
to their affiliates.
And this suggests, of course,
a significant ethical question.
At what point does a
nudge become a shove?
At what point does this act of
persuasion become unethical?
And that's particularly
tricky to pin down.
The ethics of
persuasion are complex.
You always have multiple
actors, for a start.
You have at least two-- a
persuader and a persuadee.
Daniel Berdichevsky and
Erik Neuenschwander,
early theorists of persuasive
technology, put it very nicely.
"Persuaders have always stood
on uneasy ethical ground.
If a serpent persuades
you to eat a fruit,
does culpability fall on
you or upon the serpent?"
Technologies dilute
this further.
We still have the persuader
and the persuadee.
But now technology is the
medium for that persuasion
to take place.
And tech itself has many layers.
Morality seeps into the
whole technology stack.
So if I have an AI that, say,
persuades me to commit fraud,
who's responsible?
Well, me, sure.
I should bear some liability.
But perhaps also the software
engineer, or the platform
company that allowed the
app to exist unchecked
in their app store or on
their operating system.
Maybe at some point we'll
even blame the AI itself.
This requires us,
of course, to admit
what's been hinted
at a couple of times
today, that technology
is not neutral.
We don't just build mere
instruments to fulfill tasks.
Back in 1980, Langdon Winner,
philosopher of technology,
wrote a famous
essay now entitled,
"Do Artifacts Have Politics?"
His conclusion was, essentially,
well, damn right, they do.
And Robert Moses was--
Winner gives the example
of Robert Moses, rather,
as the New York City town
planner back in maybe the '40s,
something like that.
And Moses was a racist.
And although it's
slightly disputed,
it is alleged that Moses built
intentionally low bridges
covering the freeways on the
way down to Long Island beaches
so that black people who
traveled mostly by bus
wouldn't be able to get there.
Even a bridge-- this hulking
monstrosity of hundreds of tons
of concrete and steel and iron--
have moral impact.
It's a mistake to separate
technological capabilities
from human capabilities.
These things act together.
We're interwoven,
hybridized actors.
Things change what people
can do and how they do it.
It is true that guns on
their own don't kill people.
But a gunman certainly can.
So we have to reject
this idea of neutrality.
We have to accept the inevitable
social, political, and ethical
outcomes of our work.
The clear ethical risk
in all this, of course,
is that we eliminate free will.
That's hyper-effective
persuasion
diminishes human
agency, which is
something that lies
at the heart of almost
every popular dystopia.
And the power dynamics
of hyper-nudge
strike me as
particularly worrying.
Because they have the
advantage of scale,
they can learn from
millions of people.
Because they can shift
strategies at will,
hyper-nudge algorithms are
highly potent but essentially
invisible, diluted by
the technology stack
using obfuscated data
flows and operating
on the thresholds of consent.
And this creates a
significant power imbalance.
If we aren't careful, we'll
build systems in a way
that we won't know
who's persuading us.
We won't know their intent.
And we won't know their methods.
This means that people
will have no recourse
to collectivize and to contest
these systems because they
won't even know that
they're operating.
We will become blind to our
own manipulation, which,
of course, makes this a
terrifically valuable prospect
for the high-stakes
games of politics.
We all know far too well
how this is heading.
The recent headlines
about Cambridge Analytica
clearly point in that direction.
The nature and structure
of connected technology--
and particularly the web--
already privileges
certain belief systems.
Hypertext has a way
of breaking down
centralized linear narratives.
It encourages,
instead, apophenia,
the habit of imposing
relationships
on unconnected things.
So you could argue that
the structure of the web
already affords conspiracy.
Where this gets
particularly alarming for me
is if we combine that tendency
with evidence collapse,
with falsifiable
audio and video.
So we can have soon
an AI that knows
how to manipulate
us individually,
and that can generate the
evidence required on demand
to support that manipulation.
It's a particularly
scary prospect.
Now, we might counter.
We can say we can build
trust-based technologies,
things like cryptography
and blockchain technologies.
And you know, maybe that will
help alleviate that situation.
But these are
complex technologies.
We may end up, very likely,
in a situation where they're
available to only the rich or
the highly digitally literate,
and information anarchy
still reigns for the rest.
As always, what the
superintelligent and powerful
do with AI is a bigger threat
than powerful superintelligent
AI.
So what can we do about this?
It's all very well
to acknowledge
these issues, of course.
But I think we have
a bit of a moral duty
to try and mitigate them.
And I'll suggest
just four steps here.
First-- and again, I think this
is something that's been hinted
at throughout the day--
we need to materialize
the invisible.
So many of tech's
ethical dangers
stem from the invisibility
of these spaces,
be that intentional
or otherwise.
By shifting persuasive acts
into the visible spectrum,
people can make more informed
choices about what's happening.
And this is already
happening in other areas.
GDPR is going to force a lot
of data flows to surface.
The Explainable AI movement
will illuminate the reasoning
for algorithmic decisions.
People may argue that this might
make persuasion less effective.
Frankly, I don't care.
I think the power
of these systems
is potentially too great for
us to be too concerned by that.
And note when I'm talking
about materializing this stuff,
I don't necessarily
mean increasing
the complexity of our systems.
I'm talking about making
information available rather
than mandatory, creating
extra screens or interfaces
or affordances that
people can interrogate
if they want to know more.
There's also a host of ethical
theory we can bring to bear.
I've only got time,
really, for one here.
This comes from John
Rawls in his book,
"A Theory of Justice."
Rawls talks about the veil
of ignorance, the idea
that we should
design a system as
if we don't know our eventual
place within that system.
So if I'm designing,
say, a welfare system,
I should design it such that
no matter where I end up--
whether I'm an administrator
of that scheme,
whether I'm a taxpayer, whether
I'm a welfare recipient--
I should look at that
system and think I've
got a fair end of that deal.
I think designers
generally get this.
This is really a forcing
function on maybe not empathy--
that misused term-- but at least
getting out of one's own head
and seeing a problem from
multiple points of view.
I also think we should
make a distinction
between an informational
and a structural nudge.
This idea comes from
Luciano Floridi.
And he distinguishes
the two in this way.
He says that a
structural nudge is
one that changes the nature of
the action available to you.
So if I run a cafe and I want
people to eat more healthily,
then if I change the order
in which food is presented
or I move things to
the back of the store
or move them high up and so
on, that's a structural change.
Now, the downside of
the structural change
is it can lead to almost
forced compliance.
If I put the snacks
right on the top shelf,
well, anyone below
6 foot is going
to struggle to reach them.
By contrast, an
informational nudge
only changes the nature of
the information on offer, not
the action itself.
So the example here would
be changing the labeling,
not moving it to a high shelf.
That generally poses less
of a threat to free will.
The user is better able
to retain their freedoms.
And this aligns, generally,
with our social hunches
about nudging.
In 2013-- yes, another study--
people found that they were
more favorable to nudges if they
used conscious process--
so things like signage--
than unconscious nudges
like room layouts.
Again, this relates
to visibility.
It was easier in those
situations for a user
to see how the information
environment around them
had been shaped.
Finally, I think
technologists have a role
to create counter-technologies
that contest,
that protest, and that hamper
overreach where it occurs.
And this is really analogous
to the rise in ad blockers.
Maybe we'll see persuasion
blockers, browser warnings
for this kind of
thing, maybe even
some sort of nudge
traceroutes to expose
who's trying to get you to
do what within a system.
And of course, there
is a potential role
here for regulation.
But that will only happen
with continued pressure
from the industry, from the
public, and the press alike.
To see this kind
of real change, it
may take internal pressure
and occasional whistleblowing
and campaigning.
I will say that if you
feel comfortable, safe,
and respected in your
industry, in your work,
you're in the perfect
position to use up
some of that goodwill
for ethical change.
We have to try and continue
this push for change
in the industry.
It's exciting to see
over the last 12 months
the increased focus on
our ethical implication.
But we need to keep that going.
I think we're going to need
all the help that we can get.
I have a book.
It will be out in September.
URL is there and I'll be talking
about it a lot on Twitter.
And thanks for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: I think we've
got time for one or two--
I sort of promised
Cennydd earlier
we'd skip Q&A for the panel.
But I'm going to--
CENNYDD: I ran short.
It's my own fault.
SPEAKER 2: I'm going
to-- yes, exactly.
My ethical responsibilities--
so one or two questions
for Cennydd, and we'll move to--
anybody?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I work in public policy and I
want to really congratulate you
on this work that you're doing
because it's very important.
I just want to say, if
I look at the evolution
of digital technologies, it
went really from a great promise
to today, in some areas,
an existential threat.
And what I see here in
the room are incredibly
well-intentioned people.
So my question is, how
could it all go so wrong?
And how can you build
in the community more
of a sense of sort of
strategic foresight
in anticipating some of
these challenges better?
CENNYDD: That's a big question.
What went wrong?
A bit of hubris, a
significant lack of diversity.
I very strongly believe that
diversity is an early warning
system for ethical harm.
I recognize it's a
highly politicized issue
at the moment, but I make no
apologies for bringing it up.
I think a team
that's homogeneous
is always going to overstate
the value of their work
for people like them
and to understate
the value of the potential
harms of their work
for people not like them.
What was the other
part of the question?
Sorry.
Oh, yes.
I can-- yes.
Essentially, how can we
try and address this?
Right.
What are some techniques?
I'm turning a lot to speculative
design on this, actually.
There are tools to if
not predict the future
but to open the
possibility space
of potential
futures, if you like,
in sort of highfalutin language.
I'm fairly convinced now that
speculative and critical design
is probably the next field that
interaction design is going
to seize upon and partly ruin.
But I think there's
something very interesting
in those techniques.
And a lot of the work I'm
doing with clients now
is to use those structured
techniques to just
scan the horizon a bit better
and to better understand
unintended consequences.
And once they're
exposed, then of course,
you can start them to
try to mitigate them.
So yeah.
They're not magic answers.
Codes of ethics are
a whole other thing.
Maybe we'll rant about
those a bit later.
But you know, we aren't the
first people on these shores.
Academics, people in STS, people
in philosophy of technology
have been looking
at this for decades.
And it's about time
we started listening
to them as a community.
SPEAKER 2: Shall we panelize?
SPEAKER 1: Yes, panelize.
SPEAKER 2: Penalize, panelize.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Thank you.
CENNYDD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So next
we're going to have
a panel around the opportunities
and challenges of UX and UI,
and--